hello everyone with TM Prague watching
such amazing results it's very hard for
any Indian to get some spotlight but as
the Junior World Championship is over
now I decided to show a game by another
Indian international master the 13 year
old
Nikhil serene and serene achieved his
first Grand Master norm in April this
year he was 12 years and some nine
months of age he's playing a runic Open
tournament now and after eight rounds he
has 5 and a half points and currently
holding eighth place so I think the last
round will be played tomorrow and I
don't think if he can score another
grandmaster norm in this tournament
because his opponent in round 9 is rated
around 2200 so I don't think if that
will be sufficient to achieve the needed
performance but I could be wrong so if
anybody has any more information on this
tournament and this game that that will
follow you know feel free to enlighten
everyone in the comment section
including me but I I decided to show you
a game this is a game from round 5 he's
playing against an international master
from Iceland a not Jyoti Jensen pretty
sure I didn't pronounce that right but
like I said an international master from
Iceland and the nickel serine defeats
him in 13 moves so that's that sounds
pretty amazing 13 moves to defeat and
international master and it's as it is a
very short game I will also use it as a
puzzle I will let you have a find find
the winning move so let's see the game
something has the white pieces and he
plays d4 we have Knight to f6 Bishop to
f4 d5 and III some sort of a London
system east six Knight to e2 Bishop to
e7 and c3 c5 biiian our Bishop to d3 we
have castles Knight G to f3 now
b6 preparing there should be seven
Knight to e5 and Bishop to b7 now you
can't play something like ninety seven
to exchange this knight on e5 because
Knight to c6 and
black loses the bishop pair that's for
Queenie eight since the bishop is
guarding c7 and it wouldn't really
matter because you know this bishop
would be hanging so nice captures Queen
captures and white wins the bishop pair
and not really something you want to go
for from the beginning of the game so
after 95 there should be seven Queen to
f3 now we have Knight B to d7 rook to d1
and rook the c8 we have Queen to h3 and
rook to e8 now and this rook to e8
already puts black in and not another
very not very comfortable position but
it's it's not at all clear how life
should continue this game probably
something like c4 and for Bishop - c2h6
maybe but you know it's very hard to say
after Queen to h3 rook to e8 was played
and now Knight d2 F 3 and here black
black has a couple of options
he definitely has to do something about
this Bishop and Queen eyeing that h7
pawn but it's it's not very clear if you
play h6 white always has the option of
capturing better captures on h6 and if
you capture Queen g3 check if King h8
Knight captures on f7 so if King f8 now
again Knight captures on f7 and if you
capture it
Queen g6 check King f8 now Queen h6
kingi 890 g5 now with the threat of
Queen g6 check if King goes to h8 denied
f7 checks the king and the Queen and
also this is checkmate and if King f8
then Queen to f7 again with checkmate so
something like rook rook to f8 maybe
protecting so the Queen can go to f7 but
again after a bishop to h7 check if you
capture the bishop it's checkmate by
Queen captures so after King h8 Bishop
f5 King g8 captures rook here Bishop
captures checkmate it's it's a very hard
hard to play this for black so h6
definitely definitely isn't a good idea
for black here if you play something
like Knight to e4
as the night isn't this night when it
came to f3 it now it's not guarding
efore anymore and again you're blocking
the Bishop from eyeing the h7 pawn but
again I for something like D captures on
c5 and Knight captures on e5 Bishop
captures and now you're threatening of
course Bishop captures an e for the pawn
is pinned so after Knight to f6 you
captured capture and capture it's a very
uncomfortable position for black and
it's it's not a little clear what what
black should play here but the
International Master I know Jensen
played a move that loses instantly he
played the g6
and in this position the next move Nihao
siren played wins the game immediately
and I would I will invite you to find
this move and a series of moves that
follows so you know you can pause the
video I will as usual give it a couple
of seconds you know for you to decide
where you will or will not pause the
video so for those of you who have found
the move congratulations it's a it's a
very nice nice maneuver and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the
combination the idea is Knight captures
on f7 and you can't really decline this
offering because the knight is attacking
the Queen and e8 the Queen has nowhere
to go as the Bishop from f4 is guarding
c7 so obviously King has to capture
I mean after knife captors on f7 I know
Jensen resigned the game but the idea is
after King captures on f7 Knight to g5
check and now the King has to move from
the defense of the e6 pawn after King
move simply unite captures on e6 again
the queen is attacked and e8 the bishop
is guarding c7 so the Queen is trapped
and after any move for example c4 simply
capture the Queen you gain a temp on the
bishop as well and after rook captures
on d8 simply Bishop to c2 and black has
no compensation for the Queen whatsoever
well he does have two nights but two
nights is isn't really a compensation
for the Queen so yeah I'm a nice short
game by nickel sorry I think this is the
first game by nickel sorry and I've
shown on my channel I do hope you
enjoyed it and for those of you who
don't know penny how Cyrene is that's
probably because pregnant is stealing
all the spotlight so yeah I would like
to think I would like to thank mikaël
whinnery for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and I hope you're still
having a great Saturday as usual you can
check to my previous videos here I think
all for watching and I will see you soon